the Joe Rogan experience there was this
one lady who got arrested and she's got
arrested for serving or selling all
these different animals she was selling
Eagles yeah I know where the people
would get weird about Eagles but we
don't give a [ __ ] about a chicken their
biggest [ __ ] the biggest [ __ ] I feel bad
like when it's like bigger than normal
you know like like a really big okay oh
[ __ ]
yeah yeah like a really big elephant so
like really bad about you didn't just
because I feel like it's brain as bigger
so it's probably more likely to be like
sentient have to be starving to death
eat an elephant yeah it have to be like
I'm trapped in the bush and I got a
rifle I would never eat it like an
elephant like just an elephant like
they're they're like so amazing they
have incredible memories too yeah
there's this crazy video of an elephant
being reunited with I think it's a
sibling or a daughter or mother or
something like that and they hadn't seen
each other in 12 years and they see each
other they run to each other and wrap
their trunks around each other it's
crazy like they're not that is not like
a deer yeah you know deer don't even
know what the [ __ ] going on they can
teach elephants to paint themselves have
you ever seen that
no see this elephants can paint
themselves they can paint an elephant
yeah just with them holding onto the
brush with the trunk then make a trunk
then make the body then make the tail
it's crazy they train an elephant to
paint himself that's okay it's so weird
to watch that it could be smarter than
Apes then right or is it just the thing
is the thing where it's hard to tell is
like apes have fingers right they can
move stuff around like chimps have
incredible memories they have incredible
short-term memories like chimps have
better memories than us when it comes to
like they'll flash a bunch of things on
a screen and chimps can point out
exactly what they saw if they get a
reward like if they get candy yeah like
they'll give them candy if they can lay
out like some numbers and some things
like in the correct order
where you are I agree what the [ __ ] that
I see it I remember yeah we're burdened
by too much information and data and all
sorts of different things
chimps can just do it they have that one
motivator yeah but their memories
incredible actions of bananas memories
that's cause for lack of a better term
that video of the elephant with the the
brush it's so weird to watch I mean
apparently this is like they trained
this elephant specifically to learn how
to do this but it's still crazy
impressive because he's he does a really
good job like better than like a
four-year-old would like a four-year-old
person like yeah you know one of my kids
in therefore they wouldn't do as good a
job yeah making a [ __ ] elephant did
it look in the mirror and self purchase
right how does it know you got change
trying to find the exact one you're
talking about
I've been a controversial story I write
it is well I think it's controversial
because they taught the elephant how to
paint himself but it's still the
training methods are probably thinking
is that what they think that's I mean
though I'm looking too hard to the video
and that's what's coming up is like
abuse or not abused animal rights dip
shits ungracious I do feel really guilty
about when I went to Thailand just to
like train out there and I did one of
those like elephant ride I did too and I
do thank you I'm glad yeah my whole
family was like that was so fun is like
I'm not doing that again
yeah elephant so he's painting himself
baby yeah but I mean he's I don't know
how you could say he's being abused I
mean he's just doing that it doesn't
seem like there's any weird motivators
other than you know they saw him how to
do it they probably gave him some tree
oh yeah no I mean they they're all drawn
themselves there's more than one yeah
oh he's drawn a duck just the fact that
they can do that they can create yeah
something and it reasonably resembles
what they are what's not so what they're
making
yeah and I felt like maybe a mirror in
front of them no like a van gogh's it's
pretty close to what an elephant looks
like what it says the truth about
elephant paintings what is the truth
well he it must be like a stencil that
they had mm they're just like tracing it
or not tracing that but like they must
have trained them to make a certain
shape so I doubt that the elephant knows
that that's him
mmm you know but who knows who knows
they they could be smarter than all of
us don't they say like [ __ ] what is
it what is it squid octopus and squid
yeah stupid smart play but they only
live for like a couple weeks yeah I
think octopus live like 2 years or
something so crazy but I'm glad you said
that about the elephants in Thailand
I felt bad yeah I didn't I didn't like
the riding them thing but you fed them
we get to feed them sugar cane yeah were
you near Chiang Mai no I didn't get to
go to any sanctuaries like the elephants
that like bathe run around with them
yeah you clean them and and then you
feed them sugar cane yeah and then you
ride them and I was the writing part I
was like I don't want to do this I
thought they had they have that big hook
the hook when they so when we went to
the one that we went to they have this
like big pole with a little hook on it
and it never like hit some or anything
but it's just resting on like their
shoulder those like they're like kind of
training to like I figured like that was
what they used to like get him to behave
so it's like it's like someone sitting
next to you with like a whip you know
like you know what it could do it didn't
do anything but you just know it's there
no they displace one thing that I will
definitely say is that they treated
those elephants like pets
yeah treat them really well they pet
them and you could tell they had a sweet
relationship with them like the elephant
would wrap their trunk around the people
and the people would rub their head they
wanted to be around those people and
then they would feed him a lot of sugar
cane like we had these big stalks of
sugar cane and they would make you for
see the
idea was a real pill rehabilitation
thing for elephants and a lot of the
elephants had been in circuses and zoos
and things like that and then they
actually had reintroduced a lot of them
to the wild and when we were there these
elephants were not in cages they were
free roaming
oh that's I never it was crazy their
power they just wrap their trunk around
[ __ ] just pull it out of the roots and
then just start eating it like but then
they're also really gentle really gently
they'd grab stuff out of your hands just
like like they just like they fill your
hand and then they grab the tree around
it yeah but they can hey I know they're
really they're [ __ ] smart yeah that's
right a [ __ ] they can bring those
elephants back to a place where they can
exist in the wild because they basically
everything that's in the jungle they
just grab it and eat it they know what
to do so while we were hanging out with
them they're just pulling trees out of
the roots and just eating them right
there but they're there their
disposition is so interesting it's just
so interesting a be around them it's
bacon gentle big and gentle I mean
they're so [ __ ] big and they help you
get up on them they lift their leg up
and you stand on their legs yeah and
then you pull yourself up onto their
back and then you hang onto this rope
that's around them they didn't seem to
mind that you on their back but still it
felt like I would rather just feed him
and pet him yeah like I'm gonna do that
in a while buddy yeah then they go down
to this pond and then you wash them in
the pond and everything it was yeah it's
interesting
oh it was really cool I wanted to go up
to Chiang Mai but we were we were at
this place called a jazz right there
that's exactly where we were ah so
pretty yeah that's exactly where and so
you go out there and you pet them they
love it that was like keep baby
elephants frolicking at all there oh my
god they loved the bathtub but that
water is filled with [ __ ] you just [ __ ]
in the water
elephant [ __ ] it's probably lucky in
some cultures
[Applause]